hit with a class action lawsuit from
coverage who spent thousands of dollars
what was supposed to be a luxury weekend
of food art and music it didn't turn out
quite that way now they're under fire
their role in the now infamous fail
[Music]
good afternoon
i want to
i want to start
stop it i want to start by thanking the
legal team at she-hulk attorney at law
and my publicist jordan beckwith at
beckwith skank models putting out some
legal fires this morning
and i also want to thank the la fire
department for putting out some literal
fires this morning
i want to begin by
apologizing to the fans of the break
room my breakers
my roomies
my trash bags
when i dreamed up tomicon all those days
ago i never dreamed we'd soar to such
big heights
sometimes when you soar too high
you're gonna get burned
there's been a lot of
news around tomicon today and most of
its lies perpetrated by the mainstream
media and philip molina as well as my
many
many enemies
i want to clear up a few things
at no point was anyone asked to sleep in
a porta potty
those were simply state-of-the-art micro
suites designed by elon musk himself
yes there's a place to go to the
bathroom and yes we asked you to sleep
standing up but you know who else slept
standing up albert einstein
he's a pretty cool dude
on the matter of the 500 hot dogs
this is a gross misrepresentation
those were not hot dogs those were
extremely rare dodo sausages
made with natural casing from a white
rhinoceros
thank you to my personal physician dr
nasty for the recommendation
and i think you'll find the market value
was extremely reasonable
finally
as for the rumors i was going to release
a live tiger on the cast of the break
room as part of mandatory fun that is
outrageous
it was a jaguar
and i was told it's extremely docile
now
all those fat cats in their offices up
in the new rockstars penthouse
want me to announce that tamicon is
cancelled
and that breaks my heart
my inky breaky heart
so i'm not gonna do it
i'm here today
two ounce you can't cancel tomicon
comic-con cancels you so we're bringing
it back this friday for at least an hour
i'm pushing for two i might stay in live
stream all damn night comic-con will be
bigger
better more intense more celebrities
more game shows we don't have shaquille
o'neal we have o'neill shaquille the
irish breakdancer
okay don't worry about who's showing up
there's going to be mandatory divorces
there's going to be mandatory weddings
we're going to be auctioning off cattle
we're going to be shearing sheep
everything's going to be amazing friday
at comic-con and i can guarantee you
this if i promise you one thing friday
comic-con is going to be t-g-i-f
comic-con going in [ __ ] hard
thank you
tommy that's right comic-con has been
postponed to friday due to legal reasons
yes legal reasoning we're all bracing
ourselves for the inevitable but it is
coming this friday it's gonna be better
than ever we had a heck of a show on
saturdays you guys held it down on
saturday great workout saturday
incredible work on saturday uh this is
the break room i can't wait to meet a
neil shaquille
yeah
i can't yeah he's going on after smush
again smush is the world's best slash
impersonator he's three foot nine and he
shreds like an mf oh okay
you guys don't forget about fart simpson
either
don't give away all the good stuff
so yes if you turned in today looking
for tomicon it is still happening yes
it's gonna happen this friday it's gonna
be even bigger now thanks to all your
support throughout the week right on
saturday all the generous financial
uh contributions will be go you're gonna
see it all on screen guys i'm not
pocketing most of it
most of it is gonna go right on screen
and guess what give generously this week
who knows what we'll get for friday who
knows who knows chris fine we still have
sexy chris pine oh you have jessica do
not forget that come yeah part of comic
con is jess fest yes we also have a
five-minute brandon barrack soap box oh
my god i had four originally yeah we
bumped you up another minute maybe
because we push things we're
accommodating all of our guests and zach
holston will sing his classic gary
oldman yeah we need we need zach to sing
the gary yeah yeah also just on the reel
we didn't want zach to be here
is a big reason for why we're moving at
the fight but uh but pretend the anger
is white pretend the anger is
galvanizing it and not just the longing
in my heart for zach someone said
reverse strippers better be there people
that put more clothes on that's right
naked
you feel cheated how do you think i feel
i had the fbi at my door this morning
6am kick down my door my wives were
devastated
also you guys you just got to tune in on
friday yeah friday's this shows that we
go the craziest part anyway it'll still
be fun yeah comic con turned out to be a
very eventful event there was so much
that we had to push tomacon back people
are still on private jets trying to land
they've been orbiting they've been
orbiting california for for days i hired
kevin feige took a private jet from holi
to hall h that's true a three-minute
flight he's an eco-terrorist or whatever
we're calling kylie jenner oh my god
john rule
canceled for comic-con
without having ja rule there although he
was a main investor and to all my other
investors the checks cleared deal with
the dummies
that's beautiful welcome back ultimately
and a whole heartedly to the break room
right i hope you remember where you're
at welcome back to the break room this
is our daily news show that keeps you
updated on all nerd news and today after
following the weekend that was san diego
comic con
god bless
we're just we're talking about black
panther today we are talking about it
because there's so much to talk about
and so much that we have to just we have
to we have to discuss with you guys and
uh yes me and tommy are matching and
thank you for noticing
and let me introduce our first guest who
i love so dearly who held it down with
me on saturday erica
hey internet how's it going thank you
guys for having me oh yeah
entire show though oh that's gonna cramp
immediately hands across america
and we have tommy vector great to be
here and yes you guys were incredible on
saturday i as i had said before was
officiating a wedding but i watched that
entire hour and a half back
on delay and i was so excited i was like
this is genuinely entertaining for an
hour and a half you know how long it
takes me or how hard it is to get me to
pay attention for an hour and a half to
anything it's difficult i haven't looked
at my son in years
but he's watching right now so give me
camera four which which wife is this son
david junior david this is your father
speaking okay
i miss you and i want to take you to a
ball game have your have your attorney
call me iron it out
and then we also have brandon beric
hello hello hello hello oh hello hello
today we have some amazing things going
on but i think the most amazing thing
that you guys are probably going to be
looking forward to is our redemption
today if we get 500 today we're gonna
call eric voss yeah i'm online we're
gonna we're gonna call him li yeah live
on there we're gonna stop what we're
doing call him immediately we'll harass
him we'll ask him questions we'll talk
to him as long as we can because he's
not going to be happy about it he is not
going to be happy about it he's busy
doing a bunch of breakdowns and we're
going to interrupt for some some some
fun yeah some little funds and remember
that we also have the break room on tick
tock the underscore break room where you
can see content from tommy and content
for me and eric ganson yeah
a couple of goofs dance i'm on there
sometimes yeah okay and brandon's
brandon was our first
break room shower thought and i believe
our most liked break room shower thought
so far
what i'd consider a very
disturbing thought meditation on cyclops
is grooming yeah and cleanliness we all
want to know he uses a bidet onto our
headlines
so there's a new uh black panther poster
let's take a look real quick it's pretty
beautiful
look at it
gorgeous this is our official official
poster yes can you explain it um in
detail behind because dash will stand in
front of it for me
well we have uh shuri in the front
they're doing the the wakanda forever
pose
uh there's uh a silhouette of a black
panther in the background i don't know
who that's supposed to be if that's
supposed to be chadwick or someone else
uh and it looks like uh his mother is
there and nakia is there as well
beautiful i love it
i love it give me more posters uh lupita
mentions uh that on their call sheet for
shooting black panther to wakanda
forever uh they never they left the
number one spot blank because it was
always going to be reserved for chadwick
boseman uh she said that he would always
be with us and i love that even you see
you're seeing it on camera and you're
seeing it off camera you're seeing it
everywhere that they're still we're
they're mourning still and also paying
respects in as many out anyways they can
um oh my gosh we also get our first look
at our sexy neymar let's take a look at
this let's take a look at this man
our respects to sexy neymar yes the sexy
swimming king look at him are we happy
with how he looks we're happy
i'm happy with it yeah absolutely i
think he's like i like his uh his goatee
looks like a magician
he looks like a magician i still can't
see most of these photos but it does i i
looked at this well i i've seen what
namor looks like and i am very pleased
he's raising his hand like is tom
account on friday did i hear that rumor
yes please stop chatting that it's
cancelled i can read it with my feelings
it's on friday you can't cancel the
uncancelable yeah how many cancelable
things i say on a daily basis that's
like i don't exist
oh no oh yeah jose rodriguez getting us
there
uh wait we will come back to the super
chats in a minute so thank you uh black
panther in finally black panther is
ending phase four this was the uh
if you were watching saturday stream i
walled out i walled out a lot i
definitely walled out the most for
secret wars but this
really shook me once we found out that
black panther's ending phase four
because you have to end on a huge bang
right you have to end with like
something huge so do you think
so kang will appear in this right it has
to yeah i mean i think so we were kind
of talking about it around the office uh
i was most surprised to hear them used
the term phase four because i felt like
they haven't really used it
uh and that's been the media because
they they're the ones that trained us on
this whole phase thing right that was
marvel and now we use it all the time
and now we were on like facebook
facebook and they're like we're making
stuff yeah
it was kind of surprising to see like oh
yeah it is space four and it's almost
phase five and now there's type six and
all this
but they do they do
they have ended on like avengers movies
before the faces but they've also kind
of ended on non-avengers movies where
it'll be like you know phase three
technically ends with far from home not
and
that's still phase three and like phase
two i think ends with like ant-man like
after age of ultron okay so there's like
a little bit of trickery that goes into
that and i think they said something at
the uh panel where the the sagas are
gonna end with the big team up
so like the infinity saga right was
everything from phase one through oh
right so like sagas will end with a big
team-up movie not the the phases will
just kind of end when we say so
you still have to be big yeah like we
know that
and i don't want the big news to be that
namor and uh wakanda are fight they're
they they
like i'm like okay that's cool i want to
know who's coming up he's gonna show up
at that end credit scene where we're
getting introduced to phase five right i
wanna know what that is i think though
right now we've seen
so much more of kang than we ever saw
thanos at that point you know what i
mean like thanos we had two little blips
we had that whole episode right of you
know he who remains maybe not
necessarily kang proper but he who
remains at the end of loki
it feels like there isn't that moment
where
thanos goes fine i'll do it myself and
we're like oh okay now he's joining
we're already beyond that so i i kind of
agree with some people in the chat it
might be another villain at the end of
wakanda forever that is
some either something that for that
brings together
uh neymar and and the wakandans or
or something that just appears in a
post-credits scene like you know i'm
hearing dr doom over there people have
been rumoring doctor doom for a long
time to show up in wakanda forever i
would love for that to happen yeah
especially but and so fantastic four is
coming at the very beginning of phase
six
right so i guess you would need to
introduce him pretty soon right right
and i was wrong about secret warriors
there's someone in the chat that was
like jessica could secret wars come out
in 2025 and i said no dummy i completely
am sorry i hate my words and i apologize
i was surprised to see that myself i
mean
i i i i i
uh ever since they said the word
incursions in multiverse events i was
like this is what they're gonna do yeah
it's gonna be a big deal and that that's
the best way to get them into secret
wars right uh and i think with
everything we've seen in phase four thus
far with all these
so much multiverse stuff so much
timeline stuff so much realm stuff it
they're gonna go what they're gonna go
crazy right uh and secret wars is just
gonna like wipe the slate clean i think
and bring us back to a new place so
right now we're just going to leave the
place yeah you know what i'm seeing i
saw all those titles go up on that on
that timeline and i thought lots of
casting opportunities for your boy there
you go get me in there somewhere there's
two more phases i'm going through a
phase right now just ask my wives
they're saying i'm the you know i'm
eating a lot of green vegetables i'm in
the gym i'm working hard and i'm hardly
working if you know what i mean
hardly working at the gym yeah oh okay
got it i was hardly working oh working
hard working so hard it's hardly what
i'm saying i hear what you're saying
i would love doom to show up i
clearly am not the aficionado on
timelines as i thought i was with secret
wars coming literally in two years yeah
what insane to me still insane to me no
director
whatever
i i do believe you guys in the chat with
doom eric voss is probably right because
he's right about most things uh let's go
on oh do we wanna okay so we got some
polls actually do you like namor's aztec
makeover you guys said 94 94 the year i
was born
that's a dead phrase that has aqua spock
which i think this is a little bit of uh
uh spock hatred going on in yeah yeah
but i also agree i like this like
indigenous kind of look to it it's very
cool it's very different uh do you think
we'll see kang and wakanda forever no no
69 said no
nice results you guys only did that you
said that so you could hit that 69. yeah
yeah yeah
everyone in the chat uh conspired to get
to that number i mean i we do know that
ant-man and the lost quantomania is like
the first thing in 2023 i believe so
february yeah which will be after
wakanda forever so it's it would make
sense to get a little kang in wakanda
forever a little bit it would be
interesting if that movie ends with you
know wakanda and atlanta's teaming up
and being like we got to deal with ken
cause they're the two most powerful
they're gonna be the two most powerful
yeah
on saturday i didn't get to get a good
look at that poster for quantum mania
but that is the king that we kind of see
in the comics did you see the like
helmet like that he's wearing
yeah so that's not the king that we saw
in loki right let's see who remains yeah
oh that's yeah sorry let's see who
reigns so we're getting now we're just
gonna get different versions of jonathan
majors yeah yeah we're just gonna keep
getting so in forever it
each one more beautiful than the last
one and that will be really interesting
if unlike you know we've had this
question of variance looking different
or looking the same if every kang just
looks the same that'll be an interesting
take on it well it'll be the same like
face this will be jonathan majors but i
do think they're going to change
drastically i mean because like franklin
richards is a king if i remember
correctly he looks completely different
but like if they're just like no that's
also good it looks just like jonathan
they just do the little like skinny
steve rogers thing though yeah they put
drugs
on like a little kid
or something like that but with with the
variance i mean we've seen people look
very much the same like the doctor
strangers and multiverse of madness but
then also loki's variants all look
different from him though there was the
the the kind of mayor one who was in the
green suit that was just like a bunch of
people they went into it tonight
everything's up for grabs they went into
it
and i can't remember what interview
where they kind of discuss like why
loki's variants look different and
someone else's look the same they were
saying like loki's look very different
because of the chaotic nature of yeah
like the choices that get made make
affect him so differently that he gets
like looking so different and i think
with the spider boys uh it's kind of the
same thing like it's such a a
drastic character that they all look
different now it's all really just
casting and who owns what who can do
what with where and how we can do it
we're talking about black panther today
we're going to talk about everything
from comic con this week we're kind of
splitting it up so we're not just
jumping all over the place uh on on
every single day but as we talk about
black panther let's talk about namor for
a second okay
uh
do we think
that this is is this gonna be a
situation where atlantis has been there
the whole time and it may not be called
atlantis yep we're still calling it that
for right now
uh
where it's been around for a while and
like no one knew about it or has it been
around
and wakanda was very much aware of it
and just didn't tell anybody when they
started sharing all their knowledge
yeah i don't think it's just going to be
like hi we just got here we've been
living underwater never made ourselves
known
i
kind of think it is i think it's more so
i think that birthing scene is of him in
the trailer
yeah and i think it's more so i i kind
of and i could be completely wrong i but
i feel like they're going to kind of
fall asleep with killmonger where it's
like these people are ruining things we
need to like fight and wakanda's gonna
be like no no no no these people are all
we're all people and they're gonna be
like ah like we gotta fight them and so
i do think it's gonna be like they never
made a sound they never really got
involved until they got forced into it
so they're sucking down our
microplastics so they're like what's
going on up there
or perhaps the birth of
neymar parallels
the birth of of uh of t'challa maybe
that maybe they're not going to have him
be thousands of years old or anything
like that and maybe it's like he is the
first of this generation of uh of
are we calling them atlanteans or what
are we i mean we called it hotline
homeowner maintenance you said hotlanta
yeah
but uh but i i mean is it
like perhaps he's the one that is the
first one to be like let's get let's get
above the surface you know like maybe he
maybe he like we do a little mermaid he
washes the shore he sees a handsome
princess or prince and he's like you
know i want some of this yeah so i'm
getting on there i'm trying to hump back
well with 25 of my best friends
we're on spring break yeah that's the
breach that's a brilliant oh that'd be a
fun story if you just like fill in the
busher but i don't think uh in the
comics you know uh neymar is the son of
a human man uh an atlantean woman they
they meet much like the little mermaid
and they fall in love
uh atlantis thinks that their their
woman's being kidnapped for a little bit
and attacks everybody but that's that's
a whole other story but part of the
reason they meet is because namor's
father is searching for vibranium in
antarctica
and they're dropping some charges in the
water and it disrupts the atlanteans and
that's how they all meet uh do we think
that could be something here it's
vibranium so far in the mcu vibranium is
only in wakanda uh in in marvel comics
vibranium hit in wakanda but the meteor
kind of sent it all over the planet and
you find pockets here and there much
like antarctica or how you get the
savage land and things like that do you
think this could be like a vibranium
story is is wakanda trying to control
all the vibranium maybe atlantis is like
we're gonna sell vibranium now and what
god is like absolutely not no you're not
well i think so i think there is some
beef between the atlanteans or whatever
we're calling them and the wakandans
like it it kind of reminds me of that
scene back in and game where
uh
black widow is
facetiming zooming with war machine and
rocky raccoon and uh captain marvel and
okoye yes and okoye is like yeah there
was an earthquake under the african
plate but it's probably nothing and then
black widow was like what are we gonna
do about it and she's like it's
underwater that's what we're going to do
about it yeah so i think that was
her hiding wakanda's beef or business
yeah with the atlanteans and not trying
to even though they've opened up their
borders
we're still keeping a lot of secrets
this is our thing we're going to deal
with this and then it's gonna get uh get
all haywire and so i think that's what's
going on yeah because i think both
atlantis and wakanda they're old
civilization right they've been around
they were around and they saw what was
going on in the world and they both were
like nope
we're done i pulled a
yeah yeah and then the wife went on and
these two stayed their own and like kind
of built up i love this idea of them
like coming back and being like yeah we
knew about each other you guys you guys
are all new countries we don't want to
talk about it
you don't belong here
that's also a story line that i could
see them knowing of them and doing
something i just think they kind of stay
in their own lanes until something bad
just happens i'm really stuck on that
scene in the trailer of uh the people on
the ship
and then like putting divers in and
doing that yeah is that okay are you
guys i'll be honest i watched a trailer
a lot of times every time did i try
dissecting it no cause i was crying so
it was really hard for me to like re to
watch it and be like is this this that's
not do you
the dodc i think i thought it was i
think that's like what kind of being
like okay yeah there is something down
there and the us with its hubris being
like well let's send down some delegates
diplomat down there they put some trump
in a suit and then they sent him down
there and uh the atlanteans are like
nope no
and that's why i think the fight is is
like right you guys are no we're not
letting these people like come take over
our freaking waters yeah well i mean if
really the atlanteans should just sit
back because we're we're doing a great
job of killing ourselves oh yeah i mean
maybe they're just coming here to be
like oh how are those ice caps melting
right right we need more more water
exactly on the map where they are could
they have been affected by the uh
celestial coming out of the water that's
a that's a great question so the
atlantis is somewhere in the atlantic
ocean that makes sense
marvel comics is kind of described as
like in between north america and europe
or africa so somewhere in the middle
there the continent was described as
like a small continent about the size of
australia and of course there's other
things like lumuria and other ones i
don't think we'll get into that
uh but it was relatively big and it sank
it i think tiana came out
it did not break so did you
it's just that side of the it's just
that
uh team like kind of it seemed like he
was coming out in the pacific the hand
but in theory like his foot might come
out there i
yeah like because they were where that
volcano was that was kind of like
indonesia area so that's why i imagine
his hand was in his head maybe his foot
poked i like this idea that his foot
poked atlantis what the hell is going on
up there maybe that will finally be when
we address this
that's why atlantis is pissed
and ryan coogler is like we are talking
about
we ran a poll in the chat that said if
atlantis and wakanda fight who do you
think wins and 63 said wakanda hell yeah
i think they're gonna come together
they're gonna come together i don't
think namor is an actual villain let me
tell you something when people fight
nobody wins
okay
hey guys
you're in your microphone okay i'm
talking to my boobs
no you're mine
the end of black panther
they sort of announced the their
presence to the world everyone finds out
about wakanda
there's got to be some fallout from that
i'm wondering if at the end of the movie
it's inspired people to be like there
are other hidden nations and we gotta
find we gotta go find them and imagine
that ship is and they're just like james
cameron's like i know
that there's some people living in the
ocean
and now neymar is like screw you guys
you're the reason people are trying to
come find us
you up on that idea
thank you i was like this is what i
would do if i was in that world i love
the idea too if there's some past beef
where like wakanda
put down atlantis
and then atlantis sees that like the
world's embracing wakanda and they show
up and they're like whoa
these are not good people like they
damaged us they destroyed our cities
they've had plenty of fights in the
comic books in this trailer we see a
flood and it looks like wakanda's
getting flooded which does happen in the
comics it's crazy neymar hopped up on
the phoenix force sends a tidal wave and
wipes out like basically
all of wakanda kills a ton of innocent
people destroy cities what kind of gets
their revenge don't you worry about it
they they have a lot of beef they're
destroying each other a lot but this
looks like it's going to happen in this
movie yeah uh dude and you know you guys
in the polls think wakanda's going to
survive will they survive this like what
do we think is driving to this point
yeah of
what's going wrong i mean we know
t'chaka's got some skeletons in the
closet
maybe he did stuff to it
as well
i just i just can't wait for angela
bassett to scream at him
back up give me 20 feet
um max savage sent in a super chat that
also was asking about uh the celestials
i just lost it could the atlanteans be
pissed about the dead celestial in the
ocean and nobody's doing anything about
it
if it's like seeping stuff into the
ocean they could be like yeah there's
like leaking all over the place and
let's be honest let's be a little let's
be a little uh
pull the curtain back that's a good way
to you know kind of link in the eternals
without having to like actually link in
an eternal like yeah hey the events of
that movie do matter to the mcu uh just
because of this and don't worry about
the other guys
um vortex man 11 also sent in a super
chat with a good point he was saying the
wakandans and atlanteans have probably
been fighting for a long time why else
did a relatively unknown country with
very little insider interaction have
such a massive standing army like we saw
in infinity war
that's a great point they've been
getting ready but like they've been
getting ready
but why were they getting ready because
they knew they had to fight with these
people that's why i'm like i think it
they they're they're getting ready also
not not the same as black panther but i
do think with black panther one how he
was like um daniel kahlua's character
was like no we got to fight him and
black panther was like no i'm the prince
when i say ghost namor is probably like
we gotta fight and people are like
should we and he's like no we're going
to i'm going to stand by i'm going to
stay on my ground yeah or stay in my
waters
stand your water's lost
no the chair did i hope they have the
stand your waters laws
in atlantis
if if laws and butt touching are
bringing you down
we want to thank our friends at
betterhelp
we uh for sponsoring the break room this
week multiple folks on the nr staff have
used better help including myself in the
past that are currently using it we're
big fans of taking care of yourself and
your mental well-being that's no joke
folks now you know comic-con
got moved to friday
my wives are devastated my girlfriends
won't even call me back okay so i'm i'm
doing a lot of damage control i need to
talk about it with someone so a few
folks at the channel have helped set up
better okay sorry i have set up my own
better help accounts uh
and
some people here have even set up
accounts for their family members they
have never tried family therapy before
and just need a little encouragement how
wonderful is that it's a really great
way to get help to help someone you love
invest in their own mental health health
better help online therapy will assess
your needs and can match you with your
own licensed professional therapist in
less than 48 hours i'm telling you guys
i did this myself i have an appointment
they know all about me things that no
one else knows i over shared and it
still only took 10 minutes to set up
it's more affordable than traditional
online offline therapy and financial aid
is available check out all their
testimonials they have on their website
a website of real users sharing their
experience with better help therapists
and
they have a special offer for our
breakers our roomies our trash bags get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
break room use that code breakroom
remember that's 10 off your first month
of online therapy at better
betterhelp.com
slash break room we thank them and thank
yourself for taking care of your own
mental health guys this is a gift to
yourself all right now speaking of gifts
to myself
it's time for mandatory fun
keeps on giving
comic con may be postponed but that
doesn't mean that this segment ain't
gonna own hit the graphic again
that's right tomicon may be delayed but
that doesn't mean that this segment
won't slay hit the graphic again
another one another that's right
comic-con may move may have moved
forward on the calendar but that doesn't
mean that we are not going to nail enter
this segment yeah again
we keep getting better yeah
i think i'm worried
may have been extended just four more
days but that doesn't mean that this
segment won't satisfy you in four play
ways hit the graphic again
i don't know what number we're on
all
it's right taking wind out of my sails
by no budding
four improvisers up here comic con gave
us an absolute average avalanche of news
and announcements
it's all very exciting but we're nerds
so we still need to complain yeah yeah
now for those of you who are old like me
there was a man on tv named andy rooney
and there was a show called 60 minutes
which still exists but andy has been
dead for something like 20 years
20 years also yeah we are i watch 60
minutes and he's been dead for a while
now but his spirit lives on in this
segment which we're going to call
comic-con gripes now andy would complain
about things like why do bicycles only
have two wheels
for my money bicycles should have at
least four wheels and they should be
called cars
they should have motors how come people
take the dogs outside back in my day
dogs were made for eating uh
and things like that so now
if you know you know now
everybody here is going to get a chance
to do their comic-con gripe i want to
start uh at the end with eric what is
your comic-con gripe for today my
comic-con gripe for today this monday
here break room is that we didn't get
any information on the marvels yeah
you know i miss marvel had a fantastic
first season one of the highest rated
marvel properties ever uh especially on
rotten tomatoes and we got no indication
of why
carol danvers is in her bedroom in new
jersey uh we don't know where kamala
khan is where she is in the whole
infinite multiverse i wish we got some
information on the marvels you know
where is uh spectre or one of her many
names
also which name is she giving her she's
got something
i think it's phone calls photon was her
mom's name and the plaque in wanda
vision it said her mom's name and then
it said photon and i think she's just
going to do a photon to photon junior
photon daughter spectrophone right slap
yeah
well we would know that if marvel had
given us the info on the marvel
song spectre rambo
bum
i don't know what that song's for
uh i'm joking i know inspector gadget
i'm not that young
i almost had a break right i almost
threw one of these gray hairs at you
okay y'all i get it
i'm a baby and this baby's got a lot to
complain about and not too much because
i i was given the black panther trailer
i was satisfied you gave me a little bit
i said
but you know what i was not satisfied
with and i'll be honest
i wanted more i don't think they know
what they're doing with the midnight sun
so they're just giving us a little bit
they didn't give us enough i'm also
irritated about everything that's a
mutant but i'm more mad about blade i
wanted to get more information for that
and for werewolf by night i wanted to
know and people are like oh they'll give
more a d23 and i'm like i'm not asking
for d23 i'm asking for san diego comics
i don't d23 is for everything too it's
like for all disney stuff and i'm fine
with that but san diego comic-con
girl you better pull you better pull a
lot and i wanted more blade information
not just here's the look at what it's
going to look like i was like
my boys you guys need to
figure out what we're doing with the
midnight suns
and give me more information or else i'm
going to steal kevin foggy's hat and his
big head is going to be out in the open
just getting sunburned yeah it's just
going to begin something they didn't
even mention moon night at all i don't
even think it was on their little
graphic okay remember it was last night
yeah oh yeah there was like some mystery
holes in phase six right there's a lot
of well yeah they said at d23 they're
gonna fill in everything on you
oh okay come on me me me and eric maybe
me and eric also go to d23 who knows who
knows we went to celebration please
please can we go my turn hey john do me
a favor play the graphic of sexy neymar
all right here for my money one thing
i'd like to see less of
i love your is people showing up in
their actual costumes at comic-con it
looks stupid it looks ridiculous
they you they have effects teams and you
know all these people spend all this
money to make these suits look
incredible with on these cameras and
then we get everyone showing up in
spandex at the con in character it's
cringy it's embarrassing playing
characters on a streaming show or tv is
embarrassing everything should be
non-fiction everything should be real
and everything should be shot
documentary style if i mean unless
jonathan majors is going to be king the
conqueror 24 7 take the costume off
unless the rock is going to be black
adam take the costume off i just
realized that i'm not attacking any
white people so this could become
problematic i want to go ahead this
isn't live is it go after the high
evolution are you two michael bechtold
are you thomas is this live
this is live i gotta go oh boy oh god i
see i see your point though but like
john cena did a great job wearing this
piece maybe because his cousin is
nothing his costume is pajamas because
he's his wife
he's because he's a beautiful christian
white man no listen to me
this is more of a compliment to the i
realize it sounds like
their costumes look amazing on film okay
they're caught in the artwork the poster
for ant-man that has kang in it he looks
great with the head piece
in person he looks like it's bad tron
cosplay
he looks like it's the waffle tron cost
this segment is awful no no i'd be just
going in on going in on them there tommy
racist
i told you new rockstars is trying to
erase me yeah your rock stars is trying
to destroy me
i'm on your side here because there's
nothing like
when you're at a con
uh and you see like boba fett or
something who looks cool and you're like
oh i'm gonna go get a photo yes and you
walk up to me like hey can i get a phone
and you're just like yeah sure yeah and
you hear the plastic yeah clinking
together
you guys are doing a great job with
cosplay it's not your fault i wish
everyone had uh machines that cut metal
and could build whatever you want but
when you hear a costume move it really
takes you out of it it really takes you
out of it
does it it takes me out here's who i
want appearing in costume
stripper ella oh okay any of the magic
mike reverse stripper yes jessica
clemens any of that those are all fine
here's who doesn't need to show up in
costume everyone else everyone else just
wear a polo and some khakis okay and
what other acoustic will they be holding
that's on fire
hey
how come there's been no news about a
new dick tracy project warren baby give
up the rights
why don't you anyone else do jake tracy
it's time for the new adventures of
young dick tracy you already set it up
in the movie you had a kid that he that
he uh he fosters and then he adapts who
goes by the name dick tracy jr let that
kid grow up in the mean gritty streets
of wherever dick tracy takes place
and now there's new gangsters even
though it's 50 years later it's still
the 20s
and you got tommy two eyes and you got
frankie four ears and you got a billy
stub fingers and they're all bad
gangsters make another dick tracy
project why are you making me wait so
long give up the rights warren baby give
him up more like warren haiti more like
warren haiti
haiti's i know stop don't because
don't feed them any more fuel i said
my own company
started the fire in this chat which we
will be talking about afterwards
all right play the graphic one last time
so i can say goodbye
[Laughter]
i don't think it was him i don't think
it was him but he sometimes takes over
you never know when phillips has already
chat hiding in the shadows we've had a
lot of great super chats today thank you
for sending in those super chats we're
about halfway to calling eric we don't
have much time left on the show i don't
know what do we do do we discount it uh
uh no they gotta earn it i'm not getting
yelled at by eric that's a fair
money but this is a fair point because
we are gonna get in trouble almost as
much trouble as the new rockstars
commoner
so
uh we did have some we have had some
great super chats uh uh today one of
them came from uh kelsey salmonego yeah
kelsey
salmonego i'm saying that wrong i
apologize where in the world is kelsey
salmonega where the hell uh she was
saying what if wakanda was charged with
protecting atlantis but they failed and
now neymar is exacting revenge
i think that would be pretty good too
if they were like we had a deal and what
kind of has to be like oh yeah rest of
the world there's atlantis we didn't
protect them but now they're pissed bye
go invisible go invisible close it down
we're just mountains and trees now yeah
um but yeah there was so much uh in this
trailer uh
and at the very end we saw
the suit the suit and some claws coming
with the gold trim had some claws in it
you know john and i were discussing is
that a masculine form is that a feminine
form very hard to tell very
gender neutral of the form couldn't tell
it was a good butt regardless good but
whoever's but it is great butt work
tommy doesn't think your suit looks good
in person but i think it looks like i
think your butt looks good on screen but
who do we think is in the suit okay is
it shuri is it a coy is it riri probably
not i mean she's gotta build another
dude
is it raimondo it's angela
nakia
killmonger back from the dead i don't
think it's in baku because i liked him
but i just like the message they had in
the first movie where he was just like
no i'm gonna fight to get it i'm not
gonna just take it danny went to high
school in brighton new york just miles
away from me but he claims he's from
brooklyn winston
come on and claim your rochester roots
with us
from new york yeah he's from i think i
think he's born in brooklyn he's so fine
um for a while i was in rochester
lived in oakland so yeah it could be out
and i'm
and i'm from seattle um and i'm also the
star of black panther
i think it's angela bassett
i think it's angela bassett and also
i said that to my mom i was like i think
it's and i think it's angela she was
like oh wasn't she a little bit older
and i was like do you know this woman's
workout routine the workout routine that
most celebrities have to go through is
so insane but angela bassetts is really
insane she drinks she eats like one cup
of yogurt a day and works out three
times a day they put gwen and poutro in
a suit like yeah
someone said pepper pops obviously
now that sounds like an idea i can get
by
no i i do think and i think that would
be a really sick thing i really liked
angela bassett i i wanted more of her in
the first movie because she was like a
mom that was like mourning and she
didn't talk as much but in this i'm like
and that should be a mom this morning
who's talking a lot but she's morning
two not just one and she's like i uh my
family's died you think my i am the pr
i'm the queen of the strongest place in
the world i was like go off i said pop
off who has real wakanda in her that's
like boasting it that woman is i would
like to see it i think it should be
nakia
uh i think she would be like a great
choice okay makes a
a good point but like i think she's like
being head of the dora milan i don't
think she wants to be the black panther
my question is where they got some more
heart-shaped herb hidden away didn't
kill me or burn anything
they can still make it and i i can't
remember in which one they did but they
uh suri could
make like a faux version yeah she can
make a faux version of it and i think
that's why riri's there is to help her
making it so i think they're going to be
making artificial uh some impossible
harsh record some impossible
heart-shaped and then bass comes down
and like i'm gonna oh sorry beyond
heart-shaped
that's going to show up and put her
heart in the ground or whatever like the
herb
oh my god
uh hydroponic weed yeah yeah yeah they
actually are just gonna smoke a blunt
and then go see a bunch of hey that was
like yes last week when we had to think
of weed strains actually two weeks ago i
think where does the time go where does
the time go what about like a killmonger
from another timeline people are this is
the multiverse saga we're in the
multiverse saga there's people that i
read a bunch of theories about online on
twitter that are like a big part in
different takes obviously different
interpretations eric killmonger being
like uh uh his in his last words of like
put me in the water with the rest of my
ancestors and then if his body was like
given to the water the ocean and they
found him in the ocean
oh and you think the atlanteans somehow
provided
say we can save you yeah yeah dude yeah
and i i like that theory i know it's
different up to different
interpretations that uh that little that
monologue but i write i it spoke to me
and i liked it people seem to be liking
uh killmonger theories he's easy but i
like the killmonger theories it looks
like the chats also liking
shuri put a shuri in the suit i mean
it's possible i mean it's happening in
the comics yes that's probably what's
gonna happen she also does become queen
in in the comics
uh she's she's the one who like attacks
atlantis at one point
uh neymar tries to make a peace deal
with t'challa and he's like i'm not in
charge right now you got to talk you
have to go through the official channels
it doesn't go well
not for atlantis but that was revenge
for the title wave they should have
never tried to win they should have
never titled them either way do you
think we're gonna it's gonna be like
immediate or later in the film where we
see the person in the suit
do you think that fight scene between
him and more are gonna show up like last
minute i think it's too because they're
gonna be like we can fight them and then
be like we need more we need a little
bit
for the majority of the movie there will
be no one there will be no black panther
i mean but marvel has like a pretty good
track record of not showing third x
stuff
in trailers they certainly have they did
it with like shanxi you know we
eventually but they were putting out a
lot for seanchi i don't know but you
have i don't know but it's different
when it's black panther because it's
like we all have been asking who's going
to be black panther so i think that's
when they finally put the third act in
the training and they were like they
kind of had to show it in the trailer
will be there will be an answer yeah
there will be an answer at least i hope
it's not like a flashback or something
like that that would be
awful trick or treat because i think
boss did the breakdown where he was like
this is an ammo in the fight yeah when
the nails come out so i think it's today
kevin hart is in the suit someone said
wrong in the suit
i didn't see someone saying we'll save
the day at the end uh
caleb jacobs also sitting in a super
chat in neymar's mind he's cleansing
wakanda aka the x-men i mean neymar is a
mutant yeah and we know the mutants
exist now in the amcu so and he's
allegedly one of the first mutants like
yeah he was
you know there were he wasn't a mutant
then retroactively immune and they don't
even really know what his power is
because if you don't know neymar can fly
he's got little wings
what's the greek mythology the uh
he's a little hermie but like the wings
are vestigial they're not powerful
enough to make him fly in this movie
they're gonna get him to jump he's gonna
slam
on the black panther it's going to turn
into a basketball movie
jones also setting in a super chat for
tommy's tolerance class all right i
think we're good on that that's right
loving team michael rooney okay but for
significantly less money so
significantly less money i'm just
kidding alice 2746 also sending in a
super chat for your stand your water
fund that's right
[Music]
loving the idea of an atlantean room
spring so much fun uh
sorry looking at some of these super
chats
bucky is not in the suit if that's what
you meant uh
i didn't like
black panther i think bucky is
absolutely going to show up
oh how we left in um a falcon winter
soldier he's working with the door
melange right now all right so i think
they're gonna force him to come back
or yeah or something but i do think he
he's like the one the one um
like white man in the mcu other than
what's his name that can just yeah they
can just come in and just come in
whenever they want
they're like yeah you can walk around
make yourself at home sit in our hot
springs i have a question bathing
quasi pertinent to this is everett k
ross supposed to be related to
thunderbolt ross
i don't think they're supposed to be
related i believe they're supposed to be
completely separate characters because
they both exist in the comments yeah
yeah yeah they're not really gotcha okay
sorry but maybe they'll be related here
um thank you for the stormfest more lift
tyler bring back oh man
betty ross
[Music]
we do want to remind you all that we
will be having uh
comic-con on friday this week uh we
thank you all for for being here for a
time like god i'm sorry we had to
postpone it there was just so much going
on yeah uh uh but tamaka will be big if
you did
break your wrist or do any sort of
damage to yourself to get out of work
today we apologize
just extend that all the way through
friday tell him i killed your grandma
yeah tell him on thursday
that's why you need to tune in because
tommy killed your grandmother you're
going to confront me live on the air
yeah and you need to see them on the air
and i enjoyed it do we get the pole who
they think is in the suit uh it looked
like 54 percent think that sure is in
the suit yeah i mean i see it i think
it's because they've been leading us
that direction i can't wait until it's
angela bassett and you guys are right
that's a good guess
i don't think angelo bassett was on that
poll that's why uh i'm sorry she wasn't
there oh neither is lupita
yeah yeah
oh you're like we could only do four and
you chose there's too many possible
no it's okay it's okay it's okay do you
think it's possible that multiple people
could be wearing a suit oh imposters are
they're gonna pull up
and thunder where like everyone gets to
be a black woman
if it's uh if it's a lupita's character
i 100 could see her going that route
being like this is shared amongst us
this is a we are black people like a
captain planet scenario yeah
you can still work without the other
kids yeah yeah yeah
i could see her going that route i just
wanted to be
i i'm so sorry i'm gonna keep riding
this angela basket it's only because i'm
like it's also an older person coming
back into the mcu i mean yes we have um
uh michelle pfeiffer uh
is the original wasp uh yeah it's uh
what's your name though it's uh
um i'm happy to like see those people
who join in and like in the movies and
i'm like we could also get angelo
bassett
angela bassett in that suit yeah uh who
won best comic-con gripe
they loved they justice league blade
marvel tracy came to a also it's tracy
t-r-a-c-y how dare you yeah the pool was
just how dare you think paul ray my boy
dick tracy i'm thank you to the 20 that
are right
don't want to get into it
guys tomorrow we're going to be digging
into kang dynasty and secret wars as we
continue to break down all of this
awesome comic-con news that we got
and don't forget we're still doing our
clip of the week on our discord so be
sure to submit your favorite break room
clips and our discord join our discord
get on it have these conversations
on our discord it made me upset vortex
man said the elderly avengers yeah
they're only getting older they're all
adventures
and don't forget to follow us on tick
tock at the underscore break room uh and
don't forget friday's gonna be tomica
and your folks are making it happen and
it's gonna happen
uh thank you all for joining us today we
hope you had a great monday so far so
much fun going into work talking about
comic con with all your friends oh and i
i just want to make one announcement oh
i i just recently heard from team
michael beck told he will be releasing
not one
not two
but three trailers for the upcoming
slate whoa
films on friday so for those of you that
are fans of him uh he's gonna be
releasing three trailers of films on the
slate and i'm told they're all rated uh
nc 17. all right anyone is a fan of guys
there's a few of them there's a few i
love tommy i don't like to see michael
vicksburg
i don't think it's on friday for
comic-con it's gonna be insane we thank
you all so much for being here we hope
you have a great rest of your monday we
love you bless you
latest gators have a great day